[Applause]
june
are you ready to hit the headlines with
us oh god could not be more ready you
are up baby you are up first up we've
got a very strong statement that has
just come out from kim kardashian she
has said that she would wear an adult
diaper if fashion demanded it oh wow
insider reports kim has not actually
worn a diaper for high fashion yet but
she has squeezed into dresses that have
prevented her from peeing for four hours
and made it so that she could not sit
down at dinner
thoughts
that i mean has anyone worn a romper
it's miserable to go to the bathroom
you're sitting on the on the toilet
naked as a jaybird awfully awfully
vulnerable
um so and that does not look as easy to
get out of as a romper yeah so um
yeah it sounds like you'd do it it
sounds like you'd do it i just like that
she would say something like this i am
titillated by kim kardashian being like
listen anything for fashion i love it
i'm like
you're gonna make adult diapers cool
i'm just curious how this came up in
conversation you know someone's talking
with kim oh i meant to ask you would you
ever wear a diaper
but you know good for her at least she's
pampering herself okay all right
all right next up
2022 is shaping up to be a wedding's
bonanza everyone is getting married this
year hi yeah i am too welly and i are
part of the happy grooms and um but it
feels like there's so many weddings
there was like a hole during the
pandemic when you couldn't really do it
you couldn't gather so i know people are
back you know in the new york times
reports there will be 2.5 million
weddings this year alone which is the
highest number since 1984. and some of
the wedding trends are going back to the
80s experts say we're going to say huge
epic 80s style gowns you remember that
like that's exciting with all the tool
right
and then over-the-top wedding cakes as
well what what do you think about this
trend going big for your wedding well
notice they said since the 80s that was
when princess diana had her wedding and
changed everything it changed the
wedding industry as we know it
and
i also
discovered a story to compliment this
one
and it's proof that you can get a
maximal wedding by paying minimal bucks
usa today reports that kiara and joel
newlyweds from los angeles are going
viral for their low-cost wedding they
got married on a beautiful california
cliffside for a grand total of five
hundred dollars yes the wedding dress
itself was 47 and kiara said her mindset
was why spend a lot for a dress i'm
gonna wear once and congratulations to
karen joel because you know some people
opulence and kind of
they find it worth it to spend all their
money on this big day some people do not
have that option or even do and just
don't have that kind of mindset they're
more frugal so i love this minimalist
maximalist approach you do what's right
for you all options are awesome
absolutely right if you want to go big
go big
i love that they got it in 500 i'm
planning a wedding right now i'm telling
you i would love to do it for five
hundred dollars oh i've met your wedding
planner i i don't happen it's he's like
a little bit like frank from
my father
oh my god
favorite martin short character oh my
god more bling on his body he sent me a
bouquet of flowers that they wheeled in
ross and i was like oh my god
you're gonna have a couple more zeros i
don't i don't want to think about it i
don't want to think about it but i will
tell you this it is like it is a special
day go big or small it's your day
exactly all right up next how old red
hot is the housing market right now uh
if you look at prices they're crazy and
this one caught our attention it's a
four bedroom in virginia complete with
strangers living in the basement and it
just yes it just sold for over asking
yahoo reports the house literally
described as needing 25 000 in repairs
for leaks and rot went for over 800 000
in cash
and whoever bought it agreed to more to
terms uh which included no access to the
lower level where there is a person or
persons living with no lease in place
this sounds like the beginning of a
horror movie i will never watch this is
terrifying yeah that's really scary
right i mean listen i when i first moved
to la all my friend casey was in this
apartment that i moved into we had two
people casey and i were like sleeping in
a bed together and then one of our best
friends slept in a tent in the kitchen
it was a little tense was it some of
like the most fun you've ever had it was
a blast and they often had gentlemen
callers over
you know and i would see random men in
the morning like crawling out of the
tent
[Applause]
so i'm deeply relate to this story like
there are you got to do what you got to
do pop a tent in your kitchen and yeah
[Music]